Hey youtubers it’s Charlie thanks everyone
that submitted questions for this week’s
Korra Q&A.
I loved all the Avatar Kyoshi talk that was
happening after Kuvira crushed her Freedom
Medal.
In case you haven’t seen her last airbender
episodes in a long time, remember the story
of how Kyoshi fought off Chin the Conqueror
and dealt with the subsequent uprisings in
the Earth Kingdom.
I think they’ll be relevant to Korra’s
battle with Kuvira.
Also heads up, the giveaway this week and
next week will be for a copy of the Korra
Game.
I’ll explain at the end of the video.
Time for questions, careful for spoilers if
you haven’t seen the episode yet.
Question 1 - Dennis asks, I get the feeling
Kuvira will pull a Magneto with Korra’s
metal bits if they stay inside
her body?
Question 2 - Sozen asks, How do you think
Korra will reclaim public support from Kuvira?
Question 3 - Akira Nasuki asks, do you think
Mako convinced Wu to make
a difference?
Question 4 - Nayef asks, will they build a
Nuclear Bomb out of the spirit vines?
Question 5 - Stevie asks, do you think Bolin
will continue to work with Kuvira or will
he rejoin Team Korra?
Question 6 - Combustion Woman asks, do you
think we’ll see Zaheer again?
Question 7 - Al Oha asks, do you think we’ll
Learn who Lin and Suyin’s fathers were?
Question 8 - ISV asks, do you think we’ll
see Omashu?
Question 9 - Shane asks, do you think Zuko’s
Daughter is going to play a major role this
season?
Question 10 - Alejandra asks, if Zhaofu falls
do you think it will prompt the other world
leaders to declare war on Kuvira?
Thanks so much everyone for submitting questions,
these are always a ton of fun.
Just to explain
the video game giveaway.
For the next two weeks it will be just like
the normal giveaway, but instead of a gift
card it will just be for a copy of the Korra
Fighting Game.
It’s out on Tuesday so I will be streaming
it on my Twitch Channel.
I’m going to post my review of it on this
channel.
Emergency Awesome, but I’ll upload all the
gameplay and commentary to my Video Game Channel.
If you’ve never seen that it’s Charlie
Streams.
There’s a link in the description for all
of those, the twitch and the game channel.
Be sure to subscribe there if you like video
game content too.
Since most of you are still in school I’m
assuming yes, you are all big video game fans
too.
Congratulations to this week’s winner, I
Am Cake.
You get a pre-order for the Korra Game, If
you’ve already ordered it we can work something
out.
Right now click here for my Episode 3 video
and click here for my Top 10 Avatar Villains.
Thanks for watching, let’s all high five
and I’ll see you guys tonight for the Destiny
Twitch Stream!